[Music]
today at a press conference Donald Trump
encouraged Russia to hack into Hillary
Clinton's private email server
now some people are claiming what Trump
said is actually treason it's got a lot
of people wondering that's my cell phone
hello Godin go to its base residence
Donald Trump how are you mr. Chuck why
are you calling well listen I'm just
reaching out to every American voter to
let them know that these are lies spread
by crooked Hillary and I have zero
connection to perfect Putin perfect
putin is your nickname for president
putin allegedly olicity is a terrific
guy coded and let me be clear no matter
how much I love poop and and let me tell
you it is a deep and abiding love it
really really is I would never ask
Russia to hack crooked Hillary's email
well there's a video a video of you from
this morning saying exactly that hacker
email unless it excuse me accusing
alright listen if I would seriously ask
to cyber attack the United States don't
you think I would suggest targeting an
active SMTP port with a command and
control address something comment like
1/7 6.3 1.1 12.10 dot then I could
launch a number of remote access tools
and post all of this information on a
Russian hacker message board using my
hacker handle which by the way is
fantastic
Orange Julius Caesar Allison this isn't
funny it's dangerous what you're doing
goaded let me tell you what's dangerous
the Russian stealing goofy Elizabeth
Warren's credit card information by the
way Russia if you're watching
it's an Eddie Bauer visa cards got got
here
and the three digit security code on the
back is three seven nine don't do that
alright hackers buy yourself something
nice or polka Hawkins all right that's
enough Donald Trump everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you